وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو مدير مركز
الجرائم السيبرانيه والادله الرقميه
بجامعه نايف العربيه للعلوم الامنيه
الدكتور عبد الرزاق المرجان الدكتور عبد
الرزاق حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض اهلا وسهلا خليني ابدا معك من هذا
التقرير المهم للانتربول واللي وصف فيه
دول الشرق الاوسط بان مستوى الاحتيال
المالي فيها هو خطير وخطير للغايه لماذا
اولا مستوى الاحتيال المالي فيها بهذا كذا
خطوره طبعا اول شيء اشكرك طبعا الخطوط
تكمن في رقم واحد ارتباط الجرائم الماليه
بالانترنت اصبح الانترنت لاعب رئيسي ومسهل
لعمليه الاحتيال المالي لذلك الارتباط هذا
وضع ادوات معينه
للجرائم المجرمين او المحتالين عبر
الانترنت واصبح الضحايا اكبر شريحه كبيره
جدا على مستوى العالم يستطيع ان يتعامل
معها ويستطيع ان يستغلها ويقوم بجمع
الاموال هذه خلقت بالنسبه للمحتالين انهم
يستطيعون اخفاء تتبعهم لن يكن تتبعهم
بالطريقه المشروعه او انك تستطيع ببساطه
تتبع الاحتيالات الماليه او ضبط المشبوهين
كذلك الاسلوب الاجرامي في استرداد الجرائم
استرداد الاموال من خارج الدول اصبح من
الصعب جدا فاصبح صعب جدا ان انا اصبحت
الان تجاره كبيره جدا استجاره سوداء وذكر
تقرير في الامم الاوروبي الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان مجموع التجاره الغير مشروعه من
الاحتيال المالي 110 مليار يورو لم يسترد
منها الا واحد في المئه انت تتكلم على
الاتحاد اقل من مليونيرو اقل من مليون
واحد في المئه لك ان تستطيع فانت تتكلم عن
تجاره ضخمه دخلت فيها التقنيه كما ذكرت لك
بامور كثيره كذلك الضعف او القله الوعي في
في عندك عندك كذلك في المستهدفين اضافه
الى استقلال المحتالين للاجراءات لان لابد
ان نعرف ان الاحتيال المالي يتجه الى
اتجاهين اتجاه يكون الضحيه هو جزء من هذه
العمليه مشارك او الجزء الثاني الضحيه لا
يكون له ولكن تم استقلال الاجراءات بحكم
خلينا نتكلم على قله الراعي الدكتور عبد
الرزاق انا عارف ان عندك كلام كثير يعني
تريد الحديث بحكم عملكم اليومي طبعا في
هذا الموضوع لكن اتوقف عند نقطه قله الوعي
عند عند الضحيه
هل هي اولا سبب رئيسي ام ان التشريعات
ربما او القوانين او حتى حمايه هذا الضحيه
ليست بالقدر الكافي الذي يوازي تعدد
اساليب الجريمه طبعا انا قلت لك الجزء
الثاني لا الضحيه ليس مسؤول عنها لان هناك
مشكله في الاجراءات هذا يستغلونها لما
تقولي والله بالنسبه للضحيه المشكله ان ان
المحتالين لديهم سيناريوهات متعدده لابد
ان نكون يعني نعطيهم قدر من الذكاء فهما
يتعاملون اول شيء يقوم برسم السيناريو
وحسب المشكله الحاليه يعني على سبيل
المثال الان جمع الاموال والتبرعات
المشكله اللي حاصله في بالنسبه لسوريا
وتركيا الان تستغل لان الان اصبحت الان
لديهم سيناريو مش كورونا اوراق صارت ابعد
لانه كما ذكرت لك هي ترسم على سيناريوهات
متعدده على حسب الحاله على حسب الوضع
الاقتصادي على حسب قوه الدوله على حسب
توجه الدوله فانت تتجه لها راس لها رسومات
كثيره هذه اصبحت جرائم منظمه الان تحولت
الجريمه الماليه الى جريمه تقدم كخدمه
وهذا الاصعب لارتباطها بالانترنت فاصبحوا
المجرمين المحتارين لا يستطيع المواطن
العادي ان ينتبه لمثل هذه الامور لان مثل
ما قلت لك الان الاحتيالات يعني على سبيل
المثال انا بعطيك احد الامثله استغلال
المشهورين في التواصل الاجتماعي للاعلان
عن هذه المواقع عن هذا المواقع يعني
كذلك بعض القنوات او بعض
الويب سايت المشهوره او اللي هو المواقع
المشهوره كذلك يعني وش نوعيه هذه المواقع
من دون اننا نسميها يعني طبعا
واقع موثوقه ومعروفه على مستوى المملكه
ولها ثقل طبعا هي او على مستوى الدول
العربيه لها ثقل احنا لما نتكلم عنها لابد
ان نعرف كيفيه تركيبها لماذا هي مواقع
للتداول المالي ليس نتوقع المالي مثلا
الصحف مشهوره صحف اعلاميه مشهوره في
المملكه او في الدول العربيه نتكلم عنها
في الدول العربيه نعم تنشر لماذا لان كما
حنا جهاز العلمي مجلس وزراء الداخلي جامعه
نايف تقوم بتحليل المشكله اين هي المشكله
كيف يتم الاعلان عنها لانه اساسا الموقع
المعروف او الموثوق في الدول العربيه هو
وقع ضحيه لوكاله الاعلانات الخارجيه هو لا
يعلم قام بتاجير لهم جزء فقاموا باستقلال
وتاجيرا للمحتالين فاصبحت الان هذا لما
نتكلم عن دخول التقنيه اصبحت الان عوائقها
كثيره اسلوب التحدياتها اكثر يعني
التحدياتها اكثر يعني لابد الضحيه طبعا هو
في جزء من المشاركه في بعض القضايا وليس
كل القضايا ليس سببا رئيسيا طيب من
الاسباب الموجوده هو الضحيه الجزء الثاني
ذكرت انت اساسا الان بعد ما دخلت الان
التقنيه في الجريمه الماليه الان النماذج
الدوليه في مكافحه الجريمه المعلومه
الجريمه الماليه اختلفت تماما على سبيل
المثال سنغافوره انشات مركزا متخصصا عام
2019 بدات الدول الان من 2017 و18 و19
وتتسابق الزمن لان هذه المساله مساله
الاحتيال المالي عبر الانترنت اصبحت يعني
شائعه وكبيره وكثير من الناس تعرضوا يعني
لخطرها انا اشكرك ما تبقى عندي صراحه كثير
من الوقت النقطه بس اللي بس بذكرها
بالنسبه كما ذكرنا الجامعه جزء مهم جدا
طبعا اعطت اولويه لهذه الجريمه وقامت هذه
الورشه حتى تقوم بمعرفه الاساليب الاكثر
انتشارا الاساليب الاجراميه وكذلك التعرف
على الجديده وكذلك افضل مراسات وستقوم
ايضا
بالخروج بتصور بحيث انها تساهم الورشه
مقسمه لاربع اقسام مهمه انا ما عندي وقت
اعذرني بس المهم عصف الذهني هذه من احد
لهم المهام وكذلك الجروب ديسكشن او
الحالات النقاش لان هذه المهمه اللي راح
تطلع بوظائف جديده لمكافحه الاحتيال
المالي على مجلس التوفيق لكم ان شاء الله
شكرا
جزيلا مدير مركز الجرائم السيبرانيه
والادله الرقميه وجماعتنا في العربيه
للعلوم الامنيه الدكتور عبد الرزاق
المرجان شكرا دكتور شكرا لك